la commission européenne a proposé
aujourd'hui un plan d'action pour tenter
de contenir la crise
mais ces mesures sont elles suffisantes
pour empêcher d'autres morts tragiques
j'en parle avec françois crépeau il est
professeur de droit international à
l'université mcgill et rapporteur
spécial des nations unies pour les
droits des migrants mais secret pour bon
soir soir alors comment expliquer cette
hausse parce que là on parlait de 90
morts l'an dernier à pareille date
aujourd'hui 1600 alors qu'est ce qui est
en train de se passer
plusieurs choses qui convergent le fait
que nous laissons pourrir la situation
des réfugiés syriens y en a 4 millions
en dehors de la syrie maintenant qu'ils
sont au moyen-orient qui a gonflé la
cause du conflit syrien qui attendent
qu'on fasse quelque chose et nous ne
faisons rien on ne leur offre aucune
solution
ils sont bloqués dans ces pays ils
attendent leurs enfants vont à peine à
l'école ils n'ont pas d'emploi ils
n'auront pas davies ont pas l'avenir
alors dans des circonstances comme
celles là on vote avec ses pieds et
quand les états ne propose pas de
solution et bien on trouve d'autres
solutions et ses solutions nas et les
passeurs donc malgré les risques
encourus ils sont prêts à tenter la
chance à larchant l'an dernier ou faites
le calcul cent soixante mille personnes
qui ont été ramassés par marenostrum
3000 morts ça fait 2 % des aberrations
de certaines opérations de sauvetage
italienne vous avez donc 98% de chances
de passer
et quand on fait les calculs quand on
est désespérés qu'on veut mettre ses
enfants à l'école et leur procurer un
avenir et on fait des choix comme cela
alors comment on voit comment les pays
européens puisque c'est lui qui sont les
premiers touchés
comment vont ils faire pour mettre fin
il n'y a pas de solution simple il ya
des solutions à court terme moyen terme
long terme à court terme pour sauver des
vies pourrait instituer marenostrum ce
que les européens ont annoncé à
demi-mots aujourd'hui en renforçant
l'opération triton de moyens mais voilà
tout ce sont les sauvetages et avec le
cndd commandes à rome qui distribue les
tâches en fonction des bateaux qui sont
repérés donc ça c'est une première
réponse est très important parce qu'il y
avait eu des voix en europe disant qu'il
fallait arrêter ses opérations de
sauvetage parce que ça attirer d'autres
migrants là je pense que l'europe répond
non c'est pas ça la solution
à moyen terme une chose qui à long terme
ce qui est très important c'est de le
mâle développe s'attaquer au mal
développement et à la malle démocratie
dans la plupart des pays d'origine et
dans les pays de transit à moyen terme
ce que l'europe ne veut pas faire en ce
moment et qu'elle n'annonce toujours pas
il faut ouvrir des voies de migration
légale d'une barre pour tous ces
réfugiés qui attendent une vie meilleure
ailleurs il faut faire pour les syriens
ce qu'on a fait pour les indochinois ya
30 ans il faut faire un grand ami à 30
35 ans il faut faire un grand plan de
rétablissement de réfugiés pour un
million un million et demi deux millions
de personnes sur cinq six sept ans et
faire en sorte que ces gens là au lieu
de risquer tout leur argent sur des
batteries et la vie de leurs enfants sur
des bateaux fassent la queue devant le
bureau canadien le bureau d'un - le
bureau néerlandais et pour en attendre
de rétablissement en se faisant dire
mais écoutez fait là que d'ici deux ou
trois ans il y aura une solution pour
vous qui serez l'espoir et la voilà sauf
que pour les vietnamiens veut négliger
de là mais il est quelques pays autour
il vous n'êtes du même région c'est
peut-être plus simple à ce moment là
alors que là on dit on l'entendait dire
aujourd'hui que des gens qui viennent du
bangladesh absolument alors il ya des
gens pour lesquels il est clair que ce
sont des réfugiés les syriens les
erythréens on sait ce sont des réfugiés
alors si on allait les chercher en qu'en
turquie
ammann à beyrouth au liban là où ils se
trouvent ils n'iraient pas avant les
pacers ont réduire est considérablement
le marché les passeurs et à ce moment là
on se retrouve avec des chiffres qui
sont beaucoup plus gérable et comment
vaincre l'immense réticents de tous ces
pays européens très rapidement qu'ils ne
veulent pas plus de migrants il ya
tellement de pays qui ont fermé leurs
frontières
là on a un problème de démocratie
électorale les migrants ne vote pas donc
ne pèse pas sur le débat électoral et
nous avons une convergence politique
droite et gauche sur des mesures anti
immigration et ça ne changera pas tant
que les migrants ne participeront pas au
débat
donc je pense que c'est la réalité des
fins qui va convaincre les gens cent
soixante mille l'an dernier combien cet
été 250 300 milles combien l'été suivant
un moment donné il va falloir comprendre
qu' il vaut mieux prendre en main le
marché et offrir des voies de passage
légal sécuritaire où on enregistre les
gens plutôt que de laisser ce marché à
des passeurs qui exploitent ces crêpes
whaou merci beaucoup je vous en prie et
pour poursuivre la réflexion si vous
voulez savoir notamment d'où proviennent
exactement ces migrants je vous invite à
consulter notre dossier web à l'adresse
que vous voyez à l'écran